[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUTTAG: I'm John Guttag.
And today, it's my
pleasure to introduce
the speaker, Professor
Barbara Liskov, who
did not give me her bio.
So I'm going to have to fake it.
Barbara has been on the
faculty for, at least, longer
than I have.
And I've been here
about 25 years
or so I've been on the faculty--
26 maybe.
She started when she was 15.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
--is a well-respected expert
on programming languages,
distributed systems,
fault tolerance systems,
and a host of other topics.
And I think with that, I'll
just turn it over to you--
LISKOV: Thank you.
GUTTAG: --and turn
off my microphone.
LISKOV: Okay.
So I'm going to talk today
about providing secure services
on the internet.
And as I'm sure
you're all aware,
we are becoming more and
more dependent on information
that's stored online and
accessed over the internet.
Truly critical information
is kept online.
And it's very important
that this information
be stored securely.
And I'm particularly interested
in two properties of security.
So this is not exactly
the standard definition
of security.
I'd like the
information that you
store to be accessible to
you, whatever you want it.
And furthermore, I want
it to be uncorrupted so
that you can actually use it.
And I'd like these
properties to be preserved
for you in spite of all
the kinds of problems
that can happen.
And in particular, I'm
interested in hardware
failures, software errors,
and malicious attacks.
And as you know, malicious
attacks particularly
are becoming more
and more something
that happens on the internet.
Okay.
So here's some examples of
the kind of online information
that I'm concerned about.
You might have a log of your
credit card entries being kept
by your credit card company.
And it's very important
that that information not
be corrupted so that, for
example, the charges that you
think you have incurred
don't change mysteriously.
Another example is a
key distribution service
that's used that allows you
to look up somebody's name
and get back a public
key that you can then
use to access some information.
Yet another example is DNS,
the domain name server,
which is the source of all
addressing on the internet.
And if the DNA--
DNS name servers
are corrupted, you
won't be able to find
anybody that you would like
to talk to on the internet.
And then, another example is
simply a company's website.
For example, recently
I read in the news
that the Staples website
had been hacked into.
And everybody that went to
look at the Staples website
was immediately forwarded to
the website of a competitor.
So you may not think
that the company website
is such an important thing.
But even there, corruption of
data through a malicious attack
can be a big problem.
And as a matter of
fact, these problems
are becoming
increasingly evident.
And what you see
in the news is just
a small sort of tip of the
iceberg of what's really
going on, because when
critical data is kept online,
the owners of this data are
very interested in not having
you know that there's been
an attack that's caused
that data to become corrupted.
Now, my concern in
this talk is going
to be what's called
data integrity.
In other words, I want to make
sure your data is available.
And it's uncorrupted.
There are a whole bunch
of other security issues
that are obviously
also very important.
For example, privacy--
you would like
to be sure that your
credit card logs
can't be looked
at by people that
aren't supposed to see them,
and access control, the ability
to control who has the right
to look at certain information.
I'm not going to
talk about those.
So as I mentioned
before, there are
sort of three main reasons why
integrity might be compromised.
First of all,
hardware might fail.
But in addition, there can
be bugs in your software.
And finally, we can
have malicious attacks.
And the way that you survive
these kinds of problems
is by replication.
So replication--
the basic idea is
that if one of the
copies of the information
is hacked into or
destroyed, you can still
provide access to
it, because there
are all those other copies.
And of course, for
this to work, this
means that the replicas that
make up the replicated system
are going to have to carry
out some kind of protocol that
guarantees that they are
in sync with one another
so that the information you
get from the backup copy
if the primary fails is
up to date with respect
to what the primary has stored.
Now, traditional
fault-tolerance,
which was a topic of
great research interest
in the '80s, was concerned
with a particular sort
of replication algorithm
that was designed to define--
to survive what are
called failstop failures.
So failstop failures
are a very simple kind
of failure compared to
what we'll be talking about
in this talk,
because the idea here
is that when a failure
happens, the way it manifests
itself is that
things simply stop.
So for example, a computer--
something goes wrong
with the hardware.
And the computer simply
stops functioning.
Or well, so that's an example
of a failstop failure.
And these failures are
relatively easy to cope with,
because you essentially
have to worry only
about the question
of, what do I do
if I can't hear from somebody?
And you don't have to
worry about the problem of,
I'm hearing from this entity.
But it's not telling
me the right stuff.
So in the '80s,
people concentrated
on failstop failures.
And there were actually
two reasons for this.
One is at that time, hardware
wasn't all that reliable.
And so this was considered
to be sort of the major thing
you had to be concerned about.
And the other reason was
that this seemed hard enough.
We didn't understand how to
build replication systems that
could survive even
these simple failures.
And so tackling the much
more difficult failures
that I'm going to
talk about today
was sort of way beyond what
we could think about doing.
To survive simple
failstop failures,
you require 2f+1 replicas.
And I'm going to show
you why that's true.
For example, to
survive one failure,
you're going to
need three replicas.
And then, when you
run your operations,
each operation is
going to have to sort
of check in with at least
two of those replicas.
And we're going
to have to ensure
that these operations are
totally ordered so that if you,
say, modify the
replicated service twice,
the second replication-- the
second modification doesn't
sort of forget what
happened in the first one.
And that's going to require
a two-phase protocol.
So in the case of
failstop failures,
you can get by with
2f+1 1 replicas.
And you can carry out
a two-phase protocol.
And I have a little example
here to show you why--
sort of what's going on and
why you need 2f+1 replicas.
So for example,
this green circle
might represent the operation
that executes right now.
And it happens to
manage to be carried out
at these two blue replicas.
And then, at some
time in the future,
another operation
is carried out.
And for some reason, it
isn't able to communicate
with this replica.
But instead-- I guess
I should be using--
I see.
Yes, that wasn't really
very effective, was it?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Now, if I just knew
how to use this--
MAN 1: Just try pointing to
the red part of the screen.
LISKOV: Okay.
MAN 2: Yeah, you're
pointing at yourself.
LISKOV: Oh, okay.
So in this green circle is
where the first operation
was executed.
And for some reason, it
only executed those two
blue replicas.
And then, at a later time, the
red operation was executed.
And for some reason, it
wasn't able to communicate
with this replica but was
able to be carried out
with these two replicas.
The point is that because
we had 2f+1 replicas and--
or rather three replicas
in this example--
and because each operation
happened at two of them,
we can be certain that
the two operations
overlap in one place.
And that's going to be
sufficient for us to make sure
that the later
operation reflects
the effects of the
earlier operation,
provided we carry out
the proper protocol.
So for example, supposing
this was a key distribution
center and system, and what was
happening was for some reason,
two entries were being made for
the very same name and a very
close period of time.
So the green operation inserted
some public key for that name.
And then, a few seconds
later, the red one
inserted a different
later public key
for the very same name.
Or rather, let me rephrase that.
[LAUGHS]
Supposing that the first
one did it for Name 1
and the second one
did it for Name 2,
and what's going on
in these operations
is you're rewriting the
database to reflect the most
current set of entries,
you want to be sure
that that second
operation writes back
the right result for
the first operation,
as well as the right
result for itself.
So that's an example of why
we need a two-phase protocol.
We have to have one phase that
finds out what happened before
and a second phase that reflects
that, as well as the changes
that are being made.
I'm not going to go into
the various algorithms
that people invented
to carry out
this kind of simple protocol.
I just wanted to point out
primarily that you need 2f+1
replicas and a
two-phase protocol.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is it
that f+2 won't work?
LISKOV: That f+2 won't work--
[LAUGHS]
--so if we had f+2, then in
the case of two failures,
we'd have four replicas.
Now, so then, you have to
ask the question, well,
how many replicas are
involved in each carrying
out of the operation,
because the requirement
is going to be that you
have these overlapping sets
in each subsequent operation?
So with four replicas,
you would only
be able to survive one
failure, because you'd
have to carry out
the operations at--
carrying out at two
replicas wouldn't
be sufficient to get that
overlapping property.
So--
AUDIENCE: So you know
which one's failed,
though, don't you?
LISKOV: No, you don't
necessarily know that.
AUDIENCE: Oh, okay.
LISKOV: Okay.
What you know is that
these are the ones I
was able to talk to right now.
And you would like to be sure
that at least one of them
knows about the most
recent things that
have happened in the past.
AUDIENCE: I thought
because it was failstop
you know which one's failed.
LISKOV: No, because in
the case of a system
with-- in the internet,
you can't really
tell a difference
between a failure
and a lack of a response.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
LISKOV: Okay.
Okay.
So all right.
So that's how things
were in the '80s.
And the problem is that those
failstop failures are only
the sort of the
tip of the iceberg.
And what we'd really like
is replication algorithms
to survive much more
serious failures.
Those failstop
failures really only
correspond to hardware failures,
where the system effectively
crashes.
And it doesn't
match what happens
when you have a software
error, which can sometimes
cause your system to fail
and yet continue to run.
And it also doesn't
cover what happens
when there's a malicious attack,
like that example of Staples
that I mentioned
a few minutes ago.
So those kinds of failures
can cause your system
to stop acting properly and
yet continue to carry out
a protocol that can fool the
other replicas into thinking
that that node is
perfectly okay.
And what happens when
you start to think
about failures like this is
it becomes very Byzantine.
You sort of have to think
that everybody's scheming
to make things misbehave in
the sort of worst possible way.
Whatever answer you get
from somebody is a lie.
And therefore, you
have to have replica--
you have to have
replication techniques that
are capable of surviving
in spite of all those lies,
provided there haven't
been too many of them.
Okay.
And these are, in fact, the
majority of faults today.
They may not manifest themselves
as Byzantine failures.
But there's no
doubt that failures
due to software errors
and malicious attacks
are the primary reason that
we have failures today.
Okay.
So what I'm going
to do today is I'm
going to talk about how you
can survive Byzantine failures.
I'm going to describe a
new replication algorithm
to you that survives
Byzantine failures
and has very good
survival properties.
And furthermore, it's
practical, performs well.
And I'll show you a little
bit of performance evaluation
results to show you
what's going on.
All right.
So the-- in contrast to the
simple failstop failures
that I talked
about a minute ago,
when you have
Byzantine failures,
you require more
replicas and more phases
in your replication protocol.
So you require 3f+1 replicas
to survive f failures.
So for example, to
survive one failure,
you now need four
replicas, not three.
And furthermore, your
replication protocol
has to have three phases
in it, not two phases.
Okay.
And when we started this work,
it was already known that you
needed 3f+1 replicas to
survive that failures.
That had been proved earlier.
Our algorithm is more
efficient than algorithms
that people have
invented before.
So-- and I don't know about
a minimality proof that
would show you
require three phases,
though I certainly haven't been
able to think of a way of doing
it with fewer.
Okay.
Now, the algorithm that I'm
going to describe for you
provides what's called
state machine replication.
And this is what
you really want.
The idea is that
you have a service.
An arbitrary service typically
provides access to its services
by means of operations
that clients can call.
So for example,
in a file system,
you can ask to read
and write entire files.
You can also read and
write directories,
rename, and so forth.
And in a key
distribution center,
you could store a new pair.
You could read a pair and so on.
So anything that you think about
can be phrased in this form.
And really what I'm talking
about here is data abstraction.
So we're talking about
arbitrary services
that provide operations
that allow users
to make use of their services
at the level of abstraction that
makes sense for
that application.
And one of the nice things
about state machine replication,
in addition to the fact
that it sort of matches
the way that people
really do their business,
is that it will allow us
to provide service in spite
of Byzantine-faulty clients.
Now, a client-- this is the
node that's trying to use
the service--
if the client is storing, for
example, bad data in a file,
we can't do anything about that.
Access controls the
mechanism that you
would use to try and
at least guarantee
that whoever is writing that
file has the right to write it.
But what we can do with
state machine replication
is we can make sure that the
client doesn't sort of get
stopped halfway through and
leave the system in such
a bad state with its
invariance broken
and so forth that
you're sort of not
able to continue your business.
So it's really very nice to be
able to provide state machine
replication rather than the
simpler thing that many people
have worked on, which
is simply the ability
to read and write single words.
With reading and
writing single words,
you have to implement, in
some sense, the higher level
semantics at the
client machine itself.
And then, you interact
with the service
by doing reads and
writes in sequence.
Okay.
So here's basically-- I'm
just going to try and show you
here what it is we have
to do in this algorithm
in order to make it work.
So in state machine
replication, what you do is
you assume that the
operations are deterministic.
In fact, you require
them to be deterministic.
And furthermore, you make
sure that the replicas all
start up at the beginning
of time in the same state.
And then, assuming that
the replicas execute
the same requests
in the same order,
OK, you will know
that correct replicas
will produce identical results.
So the key thing here
is this thing here,
because what this is
telling me is what
my protocol has to accomplish.
I have to be sure in my
protocol to guarantee
that all the non-faulty replicas
execute the same operations
in the same order.
AUDIENCE: Is it obvious
what deterministic
should mean in this context?
It's not obvious to me.
LISKOV: It's the usual thing.
In other words, if you
call that operation
with the same arguments,
I'm sure there's
a trick here somewhere,
okay, that it should
produce the same results.
So for example, file systems
are sort of deterministic,
except that whenever
you read a file,
you get this time last
modified or time last read that
gets sent.
AUDIENCE: Right.
LISKOV: That's a
non-deterministic effect.
And so to do a
simple file system,
we're going to have to play
some sort of trick that
makes sure that we--
that all the replicas will
set the same time last read.
Okay.
So there's nothing
unusual going on here.
Determinism is the same old
thing we're accustomed to.
To rephrase that, if
you're in the same state
and you operate the
same X operation,
you should come out
with the same result.
AUDIENCE: At some
level of abstraction.
LISKOV: At some level of
abstraction-- definitely
at a level of abstraction.
Okay.
So the key is going to be
that thing I highlighted.
That's what the protocol
has to accomplish.
And it's not easy.
Okay.
So what are the clients do?
I'm going to start
talking about them.
First of all, they carry out a
little protocol of their own.
They send their request
to all the replicas.
And then, they wait for
f+1 identical replies.
And the reason that
works is because we're
talking about a system that
can survive f failures.
Okay.
So you have to assume that
there are most f faulty replicas
in the system at this moment.
So f of these replies
might be total y's.
But one of them is coming
from a non-faulty replica.
And therefore, we know that
we have one replica that said,
this is the answer.
And we can rely on that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If one of them
is fault and one of them
is good at this stage
of the protocol, how do
you know which--
LISKOV: I haven't
showed you the protocol.
Okay.
All I'm showing you is
what the client does.
So yes, we have to ensure
that the answer given us
by that one non-faulty
replica is a true answer.
So we're going to need
a protocol that will
ensure that that's correct.
Now, remember it's
identical answers.
So we're going to--
we can't rely on
any f of these guys.
But we can rely on the group
of them, because one of them
is not telling us a lie.
Okay.
But I haven't showed
you the protocol yet.
I just showed you
what the client does.
Okay.
So what do the replicas do?
Well, they have to carry
out a protocol that
ensures that those replies from
the non-faulty replicas are
actually correct.
And that requires that enough
replicas process each request,
right, to ensure that, you
know, the non-faulty replicas
are processing the same
request in the same order.
And in particular, to sort
of answer your question,
a non-faulty replica will never
send an answer to a request
that it hasn't achieved by
carrying out this protocol.
Okay.
So it doesn't really matter
what those liars said,
because we know we can rely--
if we have f+1 answers, at
least one must be honest.
And the protocol
was enough to ensure
that that was the right answer.
Okay.
So now, I'm going to go into
the heart of the protocol
and tell you in a sort of a
hand wavy sense, you know,
how we manage to do this.
So the first thing
I want to point out
is that we are using a
particular kind of protocol
kind of primary backup scheme.
And what that means is
that at any moment in time,
the group of replicas as a whole
is in what's called a view.
A view in this system
is a very simple thing.
It just means that in this
view, one of the replicas
acts as the primary.
And the remainder are backups.
And actually, we achieve
this in a very simple way.
A view has a view number
associated with it.
And the primary
is simply the node
whose replica ID modulo
the view number is 1.
You know, so we choose it
in a very simple minded way.
Okay.
So the main point
is that the view
designates who the primary is.
And the primary
is the one that's
going to determine the
ordering of the requests.
The advantage of
a primary scheme
is that one guy gets
to choose the order.
Otherwise, we'd have to have
some sort of agreement protocol
in which we'd all be
choosing the orders
and somehow voting on it.
And that's more expensive.
So the primary
chooses the order.
But the problem is in
a system like this,
the primary might be a liar.
And so the order
that it's choosing
may not be the proper order.
And therefore, the backups
have to ensure that the primary
behaves correctly.
So the backups are checking up
on what the primary is doing.
If they don't like the order
that the primary is suggesting,
they won't go along with it.
And then, that
will trigger what's
called a view change, which
will go to a higher view number.
And a different node will become
the primary in that new view.
So the way we survive
failures in this system
is by doing these
view changes, which
change who the primary is.
And the system will work as long
as no more than f replicas are
faulty.
Okay.
So now, the system is
based on two notions
of quorums and certificates.
A quorum-- I actually
showed you a quorum earlier
when I talked about
the simpler system.
Yes, Ron.
AUDIENCE: I want to make
sure I understood the model.
Are you talking also
about client failures
or malicious clients or
just malicious servers?
LISKOV: I'm really only talking
about malicious servers.
AUDIENCE: The client tries
to mess up the database.
LISKOV: The client can mess
up the database in some ways
and not in others.
Remember, it could write
bad data into the file.
And we'd have to solve that
problem through access control.
But the client
isn't able to cause
file reads to misbehave
in some fundamental sense,
because it doesn't have the
ability to execute a file read.
It just is able to ask
for a file read to happen
or a file write.
AUDIENCE: Do you
think the writes
can cause inconsistencies
in ways that--
LISKOV: He can't
cause inconsistencies.
He could write bad
data to a file.
And this would show
up consistently
at all the replicas.
He can't cause a file to become
inconsistent with the replicas.
And that's precisely what
you're getting out of the fact
that this is a state
machine replication system.
Okay.
So we can sort of survive
faulty clients, but not
really, because of course,
it's very bad if you
write bad data to a file.
But that's no different
from an unreplicated system
in which somebody writes
bad data to a file.
Okay.
So in my earlier discussion of
the non-Byzantine failure case,
remember we had 2f+1 replicas.
And every operation had to be
carried out at two of them,
or rather at f+1 of them.
And that's what's
called a quorum.
So a quorum in these
systems is a set
of replicas that's big
enough that it overlaps
with the next set of
replicas that carries out
the next operation.
Now, in this system, quorums
have to have at least 2f+1
replicas.
And to understand
why that's true,
we need to look at what happens
when you execute an operation.
And so again, what
I'm showing you here
is a system with one-- that
will survive one failure.
So it's got four replicas in it.
And we have our little
green operation there
that executed at
these three replicas.
Okay.
And so that was a quorum.
And it succeeded in executing.
And then, we
executed our second--
doesn't really matter
which is which--
operation later, using
a different set of three
replicas.
Okay.
Now, since we have 2f+1
replicas in a quorum,
this means two quorums will
intersect in f+1 replicas.
Okay.
And that's very important,
because at any moment in time,
one replica could be faulty.
Okay.
So that guarantees the quorums
always intersect in at least
one non-faulty replica.
And that's what it is that
guarantees that whatever
happened in the
earlier operation
can be reflected in
the later operation,
because that truth will
be carried through the one
non-faulty replica.
Okay.
Another way of looking
at this picture
is think about what
happened when we
executed this operation here.
It looked like three
replicas carried it out.
But this gray guy might
very well have been a liar.
Okay.
And the blue guy that
we didn't hear from
might simply have been a
slow, you know, but non-faulty
replica.
Okay.
So the fact that we
got a quorum doesn't
mean that everybody in the
quorum is telling us the truth.
And so we have to have
big enough quorums
to take care of that problem.
AUDIENCE: Is the operation
initially to talk to everybody,
or do they talk to a
quorum like [INAUDIBLE]??
LISKOV: They actually
talk to everybody.
And I'm going to--
in the next slide,
I'm going to walk through
how we sort of carry out
this protocol.
Okay.
So that's what a quorum is.
And they're big enough so that
quorums always intersect in
at least one non-faulty replica.
Okay.
The other thing that
we use in the algorithm
is what's called a
quorum certificate.
And that's just
a set of messages
that a replica accumulates
from a quorum--
identical messages
from a quorum.
So all messages
in the quorum will
agree on the same statement.
And I'm going to show you what
these statements are like when
I go to the next slide.
Okay.
So here's how we order requests.
Here, we have a request
coming in from a client.
And the client sends that
request to the primary.
Now, in reality, the
client might send it
to some of the
other replicas also.
But it goes to the primary.
And the primary is responsible
for choosing the sequence
number.
So the sequence number
for the requests
is going to be the order
in which they're executed.
So the primary
receives this request.
It says, this is going
to be request 123.
Okay.
And it broadcasts
that information
to all the other replicas.
So that's what's happening
in this part of the picture.
Now, this little thing down here
indicates that the whole thing
is encrypted.
Okay.
And in fact, we use cryptography
on every single message that's
exchanged in this system.
One thing that happens
is even this request, m,
that's coming from the
client is encrypted
with a secret key that
is known to the replicas
for that client.
And here, we're
using the secret key
that the primary
uses to communicate
with the other
members of the group.
Okay.
In fact, we use what's called
an authenticator there,
because there's a different
secret key for every member
of the group that the client--
the primary is talking to.
And we're going to
broadcast this message.
And we're using secret
key cryptography here,
because it's much cheaper
than public key cryptography.
But these secret keys need
to be changed periodically.
And so they're backed
up with public keys
and private keys that can be
used to exchange new keys.
Okay.
So the primary picks
the sequence number
for that message and
ships it off to everybody.
And it's all
encrypted so that we
can make sure that when it
arrives, it's uncorrupted.
And it came from the
primary and so forth.
Okay.
Now, when a replica receives
one of those messages,
it carefully checks it over
to make sure that it likes it.
And it will never--
a correct replica
will never accept two messages
that pick the same sequence
message-- sequence number for
different client requests.
So if a replica ever
receives from a primary
another thing saying
here's another number 127,
it won't accept the second one.
Okay.
And it also checks
other things about it
and makes sure that the client
message is really uncorrupted
and so forth and so on.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are the sequence
numbers global or just
within a view?
LISKOV: They're global.
They're global.
So the view change is going to
have to preserve the sequence
numbers going forward.
Okay.
All right.
So the primary has
chosen that number.
And now, let's imagine that
it arrived at some replica.
And the replica looked at it.
And everything looked okay.
It had never received
a 127 before.
The client message was in
good condition and so forth.
So then, what it does is it
immediately sends out messages
to every other
replica, saying, I'm
happy with that number
for this client request.
So that's what's going on here.
A replica is sending
out-- in fact,
what I'm showing you here is
various replicas are sending
out their acceptances.
Each replica is making its
decision independently.
Each one is broadcasting
its decision
to the other replicas
in the group.
And in this particular
picture, one of the replicas
is shown as being failed.
So it's not responding.
And the primary is not bothering
to do this, because it already
sort of said it
accepted it since it was
the one that chose the number.
Okay.
Now, the next thing that
happens is the replicas wait
for these acceptance messages.
And they're going to try and
collect a quorum certificate
containing one--
you know, I select
number such and such
for this client request and
the others, 2f of them, saying,
I accept that.
Okay.
So this is what I meant
by quorum certificate.
They're identical in the
sense that they're all
agreeing on the same statement.
Okay.
And of course, one
of these is probably
coming from the replica itself.
So it knows its own acceptance.
And it's waiting to hear from--
it heard from the primary to
sort of get itself started.
And it's waiting to hear from
the other-- a sufficiently
large number of other
replicas that they also agree.
Okay.
So then when it has that, we say
that the request is prepared,
okay, which means that--
simply that everybody
has managed--
that this replica has
managed to collect
enough messages that agree
that it has a quorum for that
prepare.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could the primary
send a different message
to each backup?
LISKOV: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So you have to--
LISKOV: That's part
of the problem.
AUDIENCE: --be able to create
the prepared certificate.
LISKOV: That's right.
Some of you will.
You know, this replica might.
But you need enough
of them to create--
each of them have to create
their own prepared certificate
in order for us to actually
carry out the request.
And what Mike is
getting at is sort
of what's really fundamentally
different about this system
from the system we saw before.
Anybody might be lying.
The worst possible one
to lie is the primary,
because it can mislead the other
replicas in arbitrary ways.
And at this point,
all a node knows
is that things
looked okay to it.
But there hasn't been
any global agreement
yet that that's all right.
And so it wouldn't be
appropriate to execute
the message right now, because
you don't know for sure
that it's really
going to happen.
So we have to go on.
Okay.
So here we are.
We just found that we had
a prepared certificate
at some replica.
So when a replica
has accumulated
a prepared certificate, then
it sends a message out saying,
I've got one.
Okay.
And it sends it to everybody.
And again, each replica is
doing this independently.
And now, a replica
is waiting to see
whether it can't hear
from enough replicas
that they all are prepared.
And when it has heard about--
when it receives a quorum
certificate for these prepares,
then it commits the operation.
Now, it knows that the
replica group as a whole
has agreed that this
is a good thing to do.
Okay.
And so at that point, it's
ready to actually execute
the message, send the
answer back to the client.
One thing is you don't
execute a request until you've
executed all earlier requests.
And this particular
protocol is actually
operating asynchronously.
So there can be many messages in
the process of being processed.
And when you finally decide
that it's okay to do number 127,
you'll wait at that
point in case number 126
hadn't been done yet.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is there
any specific restrictions
for replicas to execute
other requests in terms
of the sequence number where
it has to execute a sequence
number [INAUDIBLE] execute--
LISKOV: Absolutely.
Each replica--
non-faulty replica
will execute them in order.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
LISKOV: Okay.
AUDIENCE: So--
LISKOV: So non-faulty
replicas carry out
this protocol without flaw.
Okay.
So they wait to collect
the certificate.
They send out the message.
They wait to get the--
all those prepared certificates,
those prepared messages--
they sort of create
their commit certificate.
Then, they wait to
make sure that they
execute the operation in order.
They execute the operation
and send the answer back
to the client.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
Okay.
Sorry.
LISKOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My other question is,
what if the primary is faulty
and it sends a request
to f [INAUDIBLE]
processes and
[INAUDIBLE] processes
and leave the other f there?
They don't execute anything.
And later on, how will they
keep up with the other replicas?
LISKOV: Okay.
So first of all, there
was one too many numbers
in your numbers.
[LAUGHS]
So if the primary
is faulty, there
can only be f-1 other
faulty replicas.
And that's important for the
algorithm to work properly,
because there can be f total.
Basically, you were
trying to ask me
what happens if
there are f failures?
Will this algorithm be
sufficient to guarantee
that the correct result obtains?
AUDIENCE: Basically,
I want to ask about--
LISKOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --some non-faulty
replicas are in some states
while the others
are in-- are not
in the same state of
these other replicas.
How will they later
keep up with--
LISKOV: I'll get to
that in just a minute.
Okay.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
The primary as a
single point could
be indicated by the client.
Am I correct?
LISKOV: Well, actually, no.
But it doesn't really matter.
Okay.
I mean, so here's what
the client actually does.
There are various forms
in which you can do that.
It sends it to the primary.
If it doesn't hear
after a while,
it sends it to everybody.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
What if it--
LISKOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --sends
it to the primary--
LISKOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The primary
is a malicious hacker.
And the primary
deliberately changes--
let's say it's a [INAUDIBLE].
LISKOV: Yup.
AUDIENCE: It
deliberately changes
that to modify the data.
LISKOV: It can't.
AUDIENCE: And it can
do it perfectly well.
LISKOV: It can't do
that, because the message
from the client
itself is encrypted.
And it not only is encrypted,
but it has a client base
sequence number.
So the replicas can tell--
AUDIENCE: But it's
encrypted [INAUDIBLE]
multiple encryptions
inside [INAUDIBLE]..
LISKOV: If I go backwards--
I mean, I didn't
show you this detail.
But if you look here on--
up here, you see
this sort of m there.
Well, m is something that
came from the client.
And it was itself
encrypted in a way
that guaranteed that
only the client could
have produced that.
And that by itself
is not sufficient.
It also has a
sequence number in it
that guarantees that it's the
current thing the client wants
to do.
AUDIENCE: That's
what it has to do.
Okay.
LISKOV: Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LISKOV: So this protocol
works in various forms.
And one form is the client
sends this to the primary.
And the primary relays it.
Another form is the client
sends it to everybody.
And all the primary has to
do is say, here's the number.
And here's the digest
of the client message.
But these are sort of little
optimizations of the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] step
that's really its function
and then the distribution--
LISKOV: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --of everybody else.
But you can't see
in the content.
I mean, you can see it.
LISKOV: It can see it.
But it can't fake it.
And it can't replay it.
Okay.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There
was a presumption
that the primary knows what
the current-- next sequence
on there should be
something out of this.
LISKOV: Yes.
AUDIENCE: There could be
conflict between the primaries.
LISKOV: At any moment in time,
though, there's one primary.
And if there were two views--
there can be more than one view.
One would be a majority view.
The other one would be the old
view that was sort of failing.
Replicas will only pay attention
to the most recent view.
So there's always at
any moment in time
a unique replica that's
acting as the primary
as far as the group as
a whole is concerned.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
LISKOV: Okay.
Now, I'm not actually
going to tell you
all the other protocols.
What I can do is
forward you to a paper
that will contain all the gory
details of the rest of-- what
I showed you was sort of
the normal case operation.
Okay.
And to complete
the picture, there
is a bunch of other things
that have to be solved.
First of all, we have to
implement the view changes.
Okay.
And the view changes have
to be done very carefully.
First of all, they have
to be done in such a way
that any operation
that committed,
where it was at all
possible that the client got
the answer--
we have to make sure
that it sort of survives
into the next view--
so the very important
correctness condition there.
In addition, the view change
has to be done in such a way
that it doesn't
interfere with liveness.
So you can imagine various kinds
of problems that could arise.
For example, if the replicas
were too fast to do a view
change and suspected
the primary--
or imagine that a
faulty replica tried
to subvert the system by
doing view changes over
and over again.
Well, then you'd have
a system that was safe.
You know, it did
the right thing.
But it never accomplished
anything at all.
So you have to have
mechanisms in the view change
that ensure that
on the one hand,
you do view changes when
the primary is faulty.
And on the other hand, you
don't do them too often.
Okay.
And that-- those details
are all in some papers
that we've written
on this mechanism.
Another thing is that we need
to have a garbage collection
technique in here.
I didn't show you how
we were accumulating
all these certificates.
But the fact is we're
storing them into a log.
And you can't let that
log grow without bound.
And so there has to be a way of
shrinking the log periodically
so that it doesn't get too big.
And this system has to
also be done carefully.
You actually have to
carry out a protocol,
where the replicas agree
that it's okay to get rid
of the tail of the log.
Otherwise, in certain
view change situations,
you wouldn't be able to go
ahead and form the new view.
And then, the state transfer
answers the question
that somebody
asked a moment ago.
What happens if I have a
perfectly good replica,
but it somehow or other
wasn't in the act?
You know, and so it didn't
hear about what was going on.
How does it bring
itself up to date?
And we have a very efficient
state transfer protocol
for bringing
replicas up to date.
The big problem with bringing
slow replicas up to date
is that when you execute
operations and delete
information from
the log, you have
a potentially huge database that
contains all the changes that
have happened in the past.
And you don't want to have to
ship that whole database off
when a slow replica needs to
find out information in it.
So we have a very nice
tree structure sort
of hierarchical system, where
at high levels of the tree,
we have digests that represent
all the information below them.
And the leaves of the
tree are the pages,
whatever the smallest
unit is that you
want to actually transfer.
And we're able to carry
out a protocol for this
that allows us to send
just the pages that
need to be sent in order to
bring the slow replica up
to date.
Okay.
So this is what I would
call the base algorithm.
This is BFT, Byzantine Fault
Tolerance, the base algorithm.
Oh, before I go on, there are
a whole bunch of optimizations.
I've alluded to these.
Some of these are not
necessarily optimizations.
They're pessimizations,
because you aren't sure
until you run it, you know,
what's going to be better
and what's going to be worse.
But here are the kinds of things
that you can imagine doing.
For example, it isn't really
necessary for everybody
to send a reply to the client.
It's okay if all of but one of
you send digests of the reply,
because this will be
sufficient to allow the client
to tell whether it
has identical replies.
We've talked already about
this request transmission.
It isn't necessary
for the client
to send the message
with the primary.
And the primary relays it.
The client can send
every-- to everybody.
And the primary can just send
a digest along in the messages.
Also, in our system,
we do batching.
So the primary-- if you imagine
a very busy primary that's
getting hit with request
after request after request,
it doesn't actually start the
protocol for each request.
Instead, it collects
a batch of requests
and does one protocol
for the bunch of them.
And then, optimistic
execution-- this one, I think,
is the one that's
the pessimization.
The idea here is
that you might reply
to a read request before
you've actually executed,
so sort of out of order.
It's optimistic.
And with optimistic
stuff, there's
always a question of
whether it was worthwhile
if the answer is wrong.
It requires that the primary
collect 2f+1 answers rather
than f+1.
So there's a cost for it.
And sometimes you have to take
it back, because it wasn't just
the right thing to do.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: You mentinoed in the
previous slide transparency.
LISKOV: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you make
a precise statements
about the sensitivity
of this to-- tends
to slow things down
or deny service
by a primary [INAUDIBLE]
coming up and down?
Is it here or not here?
[INAUDIBLE] view changes--
things like that.
LISKOV: So the algorithm has
in it very clever techniques
for doing this sort
of little dance
between doing things
too frequently
and doing things too slowly.
And if you look at
Miguel's' thesis--
and I will put up a slide
later saying who Miguel is--
he has a quite careful
analysis of some of this.
But I don't think it's
at the level of what
you're talking about.
These systems are
very hard to analyze.
And I doubt that we
have a precise answer
to that particular question.
Okay.
All right.
So the system that I've
described you so far,
this sort of base system,
has a major problem.
Okay.
It allows a system to
provide good service,
provided it has no more than
f failures over the system
lifetime.
But systems today
last for a long time.
And so you know for a fact that
over the lifetime of a system,
there's going to be more
than one failure or more
than f failures.
AUDIENCE: The total lifetime or
just [INAUDIBLE] at one time?
LISKOV: Over the
lifetime-- okay.
So we have to close that gap.
And so we need a system that
does exactly what Ron just
said-- namely, it
doesn't have more than f
simultaneous failures.
And we have to do
this in a system--
in a world in which we
can't tell who's faulty
and who's not.
So the big difference--
one of the big differences
in this world versus
the simpler world I
talked about at the
beginning of the talk
is you simply can't tell.
A faulty replica may appear
to be perfectly okay,
because it's answering
queries and acting normally.
A non-faulty
replica might appear
to not be okay, because
for example, there's
some sort of denial
of service attack.
And it's not able to get its
messages through right now.
So you have no way of knowing
a priori whether a replica is
faulty or not.
So we're doing something that
we call proactive recovery.
The idea is we're going
to periodically recover
these replicas, whether
they're faulty or not.
And if they were faulty,
the recovery procedure
will correct them.
Okay.
And that's how we're going to
get f simultaneous failures as
opposed to f failures over
the lifetime of system.
But the recovery has to
be done very carefully
since if the replica
isn't faulty,
we want to make
sure that we don't
make it appear to be faulty
and that cause things to fail.
And given this technique
that I'm about to describe,
we can provide correct
service, provided
no more than f failures occur
in some small time window,
where small is on
the order of 10
to 20 minutes in the current
way that we run the system.
So what you're
going to want to do
is you're going to want to
think about your system, how
vulnerable it is to failures.
And then, you'll select
a replication number
that gives you confidence
that given this window,
that's good enough for you.
Okay.
Now, the way that we
do proactive recovery
is by equipping every replica
with a secure co-processor.
And the secure
co-processor stores
the replica's private key.
So the idea is you can't--
basically, the idea of
the secure co-processor
is it's not possible
to corrupt or get
at the information in
the secure co-processor
without physical presence.
You can't get there by
hacking in over the internet.
Okay.
So the secure co-processor
stores the private key.
And associated with
it is a watchdog timer
that's going to go off
periodically and tell you when
to do the proactive recovery.
And furthermore, there's
a read-only memory
that stores the code.
Okay.
So the secure co-processor,
when the timer goes off,
is going to restart the node.
And as I said before,
the recovery protocol
has to be done in
such a way that it
works whether the replica
was faulty or not.
Okay.
And a correct replica has
to be able to keep its state
and continue processing.
Otherwise, you can turn a
perfectly functioning system
into one that doesn't function.
So I'm just going to walk
through the steps here.
Okay.
So now, imagine that
the timer went off.
And the secure co-processor
said to the replica, it's time
to recover.
Okay.
So the first thing
the replica gets to do
is it gets to save its state--
okay-- write it to disk.
And this is a timed
operation, because of course,
a faulty replica might
refuse to cooperate.
So you simply allow enough
time for a non-faulty replica
to save its state.
And then, you're
going to recover it,
whether it wants to or not.
In the case of a non-faulty
replica, it won't matter.
It was faulty anyway.
Okay.
As soon as that time
period has come up,
the secure co-processor
causes the system to reboot.
And it reloads the code
from this read-only memory.
And then, you can get
the state off the disk.
At this point, the replica
has the correct code,
because you took it off
of this read-only memory.
And if it was correct, it has
the correct state, as well.
If it was faulty, it has
whatever garbage it had.
Okay.
Now, the next thing that
happens is the replica
immediately changes
its secret keys,
because if this was an
attack, the attacker may
have stolen all the keys.
And we need to be
very careful not
to allow some node that's
not a member of the system
to impersonate.
Okay.
So if the keys are
stolen, some node
that's not one of
the replicas could
pretend to be a
replica, because it
would know the right keys
to use for communication.
And if that happened,
all bets are off,
because all of a sudden, we
have more than f replicas
since these other nodes
are impersonating replicas.
So we change the
keys that this node
will allow to be used for the
messages that are coming to it.
That's an action it
can take unilaterally.
And then, it sends
out a recovery request
to all the other replicas,
acting as a client.
Okay.
So it's simply saying
to the other replicas
as if it was a client-- it
says, I want to recover.
Okay.
And when the other
replicas get this message,
they immediately change
their secret keys.
So that's the other side
of the impersonation story.
They won't accept messages
from these other replicas,
these impersonators either.
And through a
mechanism that I'm not
going be able to tell you
about in today's talk,
they then establish a
sequence number by which time
the recovery will be complete.
So they're going to say, you
know, right now, it's at n.
At n+100, the recovery
will be complete.
And the protocol is going to
ensure that this will actually
be true by the time
you get to n+100.
Okay.
Now, after this
point, the replicas
just continue doing their
normal protocol, including
this replica, this recovery.
And this is very important,
because if it wasn't faulty,
it needs to act like
a non-faulty replica.
Otherwise, the
system could stall.
Or you might have
too many failures.
And meanwhile, the
recovery replica
is checking its state using
these digests that I talk about
in communicating
with other nodes
to find out whether its
state is the same as what
the other replicas think
its state ought to be.
And if it discovers that
it's missing some state,
then it's going to
fetch them using
this protocol that I mentioned
of the tree structured thing.
And by the time we get to n+100,
the recovery will be complete.
And the recovery replica will
have recovered its state,
as well.
So that's the basic idea.
Am I running out of time?
AUDIENCE: Got five minutes.
LISKOV: Okay.
Good.
All right.
So I'm going to
finish up very fast.
We did some performance
experiments.
Basically, we
implemented something
called BFT, this little
library that anybody who wants
can get hold of.
And then, we used it to
implement a replicated file
system.
We did NFS, which is
a common file system.
And we ran it on the
Andrew benchmark,
which is a standard file system
benchmark, except it's old.
And therefore, we made it
much bigger than as originally
defined.
So we run something
called Andrew100,
which is 100 times bigger than
Andrew and the Andrew500, which
is 500 times bigger than Andrew.
And we run it on a
bunch of machines.
And in particular, we're
doing the four replicas
to survive one failure case.
Okay.
And here's our results.
This is Andrew100.
And what you can
see is that we ran
three versions of the system
BFS with the full fault
tolerance turned on--
no replica, which doesn't
have any replication.
So we're just running
the bear algorithm
on a single machine, and
then the base system.
And what you see here is an
interesting truth about NFS.
First of all, you may have
thought that it synced to disk
when you wrote something
to a file, but it doesn't.
Okay.
And that's why BFS--
No Replica-- No Replica and
NFS have identical performance.
You know, our system, No
Replica, doesn't write to disk,
because we're going
to rely on replication
to take care of the problem.
We're writing to disk
in the background.
Okay.
And we have identical
performance to NFS.
And that's because it's
not writing to disk either.
Okay.
All right.
BFS is slower.
And actually, in this particular
case, it's about 20% slower.
And the same thing
is true in Andrew500.
So we've run these experiments
with both with Interfast
and also with Solaris.
And our results show that we
run anywhere from 2% faster
to 20% slower.
We're faster than Solaris,
because Solaris actually
writes to disk.
Okay.
So we have good performance.
And I don't really have
time to talk about this.
But we have actually
defined some future--
some further work
that allows us to get
rid of some of these
requirements of state machine
replication, deterministic
operations in particular.
And also, the algorithm
I described to you
relies on every replica
having identical state.
And that can be a problem
if your implementations
are non-deterministic.
Or furthermore, you
might like to be
able to run different
implementations
of the different replicas.
So those were limitations.
And we have an extension
to BFT called base that
overcomes those limitations
by combining Byzantine fault
tolerance with a kind
of data abstraction
that even allows us
to run implementations
that have slightly
different specifications.
And so the system
as a whole satisfies
an abstract specification.
So this gives us what we
call opportunistic inversion
programming.
Inversion programming
is the only way
people have ever been able to
suggest that would allow you
to really survive
software failures,
because you can run
different implementations.
But the trouble
is that you really
can't start off from
scratch to write four
implementations of the system.
If you take off the shelf
implementations, which
are available for
important services,
the chances are they don't
do exactly the same thing.
But this technique will
mask their differences.
And so we can get
very nice behavior.
And as I mentioned a moment
ago, there are co-authors.
In particular, this work
has been done primarily
with two students--
Miguel Castro, who did
the original work on BFT
and finished his
PhD about a year ago
and Rodrigo Rodrigues, who
worked on the base system
along with me and Miguel.
So in conclusion, we have an
algorithm that's practical.
And not only that, but
it really provides you
with the kind of
behavior you want,
because these
systems can survive,
provided they're no
more than f failures
in a small time window.
And there's a bunch
of future work
that we may or may
not decide to do.
By reconfiguration, I mean,
when I talked about replicas,
there was a fixed
set of replicas.
Supposing that you'd like
to remove one and put
another one in, how do you
manage to make that work?
I thought proactive
recovery would be simple
when I started to work on
it-- turned out to be hard.
So I wouldn't be surprised if
reconfiguration is likewise
quite hard.
Scalability-- I'm
really more interested
here in the question
of supposing
have a great big
system, how do I insert
the right sets of replicas
to make the system perform
with advantages
that BFT gives you
without having to provide, say,
four copies of every server
in the system?
And it would be interesting
to look at performance
under attack, supposing there's
a denial of service attack.
Or there's really
a vicious hacker.
In the performance
phase I showed you,
we're just proactively
recovering.
But we aren't trying
to simulate what
would happen if there were
real attacks in the system,
although I must say that
with the proactive recovery,
because of the fact that we run
these systems under heavy load,
just the very act of
recovering a replica means
it loses a lot of state.
So it's way behind.
And therefore, we
are already seeing
sort of the cost
of what it would
be to bring a faulty
replica back up to date.
Okay.
So that's it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You showed that it
was about a 20% performance hit,
because I think it was four?
LISKOV: Yes.
AUDIENCE: If it were 10 or
20, would it also be 20%?
LISKOV: I can't remember.
I mean, these results
are in Miguel's thesis
up to some number of replicas.
He might not have
gone beyond seven.
The truth is people
don't typically
think of running systems like
this with more than just a--
to survive more than a very
small number of failures.
I can't invent the
analysis for you.
It's kind of what you'd expect.
You know, there's going to be--
the more replicas there are,
the more messages there are.
And these will tend to interfere
with normal case processing.
So you would expect
a degradation.
If I think about
his graph, I believe
the degradation is not huge.
It's kind of a small
linear sort of degradation.
But I should've brought
his thesis with me.
But I didn't.
AUDIENCE: Would it impact
the more exponential growth
messages?
LISKOV: Yes, but there's a lot
of stuff going on in the system
to optimize, you know,
like the group-- you know,
handling of groups and stuff
like that that offset to some
extent the kinds of
problems that you would--
you know, you might have fewer,
bigger messages, for example.
But yes, absolutely.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It just occurred to me
that he used cryptographic keys
here.
Which parties have
which keys [INAUDIBLE]
share what your [INAUDIBLE].
LISKOV: Okay.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LISKOV: So I didn't
show you anything
having to do with
the private keys.
Okay.
Everything I'm showing you
here is using secret keys.
Okay.
And--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LISKOV: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Conventional
symmetric--
LISKOV: Conventional
symmetric cryptography--
we used the public keys to
establish the secret keys.
Okay.
And that's done on recovery.
And it's also actually
done every 30 seconds.
So we're refreshing those
secret keys all the time,
using the private keys.
Okay.
AUDIENCE: So each client has
a key that it shares with--
LISKOV: One replica.
AUDIENCE: One replica.
LISKOV: Right.
And each replica
has a key that it
shares with-- in fact, each
replica has two keys that it
shares with another replica--
one for sending messages
and one for receiving messages.
That was why replicas could
unilaterally throw away
the keys that they used
for receiving messages,
since they could
still send messages,
but they couldn't receive.
Yeah, so there's a lot of
secret keys floating around,
and they're being refreshed
periodically and actually
at a pretty fast clip.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LISKOV: Yeah.